foreign
[Applause]
situation in the United States has taken
a very interesting turn and in
particular if you believe as I believe
the evidence shows that one of the
greatest indicators as to how a
particular election is going to go is
the perception of how the economy is
doing things are all of a sudden looking
quite okay for Democrats and not so good
for Republicans if the average person
actually understands what's going on and
I want to start by looking at the first
interesting indicator for today and that
is gas prices gas prices have now
continued to fall for nearly 60 days in
a row and are below four dollars per
gallon for the first time since March of
2022. now why are gas prices so
important because is is are is gasoline
really a major expense for most
households and the answer is not
directly certainly if you're in
transportation Uber drivers it's cetera
it's a major thing if you have a long
commute it's a major thing but there's
two reasons why this is important number
one many people look at gas prices as a
general proxy towards are things cheaper
expensive right now and when gas is 502
per gallon as it was two months ago
there is the perception that things are
generally expensive and when gas now
drops below four dollars a gallon
there's the perception that things are
cheaper we know things are cheaper
because inflation has started to come
down but there's another issue with gas
prices which is so many of the things
that we depend on food products of
different kinds so many different things
they come on trucks and are affected by
gas prices as well so this is an
important indicator for that reason and
when we look at the gas buddy price
charts you will see that there was this
Peak at about 502 per gallon late in uh
actually early in June and then it has
been a continued and steady decline now
below four dollars per gallon to what
looks like let me see officially what
CNN says 3 399 per gallon as of this
morning according to AAA so let's now
take a deeper look at some of these
economic indicators if you step back and
you think about over the last two weeks
what have we seen well we've seen the
stock market increase nicely we've seen
a blockbuster jobs report where a
quarter of a million jobs were expected
in July and we got over 500 000 jobs
more than doubling the expectation
inflation is down gas prices are down
the inflation reduction act has been
signed the pack or will the inflation
production act has been uh voted
approved by the Senate and then tomorrow
presumably will be approved by the house
and very quickly signed by Joe Biden The
Pact act has been signed
um wages are up and then on the other
hand you have Donald Trump rated by the
FBI with pictures of his toilet with
documents in it circulating as he pled
the fifth yesterday more than 400 times
when deposed by the New York attorney
general things aren't looking very good
for Trump World and things are looking
increasingly good for uh Joe Biden now
is it good that gas prices are low
one of the things that we have to
understand is that it's not necessarily
good for the long term for gas to be so
cheap in the United States I have said
before
gasoline prices in the United States are
not accurate in the sense of
representing the true cost of a gallon
of gas particularly including the
environmental cost of a gallon of gas
when gas is more expensive people tend
to use less of it and when you look at
Europe you see smaller vehicles and
people being much more judicious in
terms of their road trips I've done road
trips and done extensive driving in let
me think now Spain France Italy
um at minimum if not other places as
well and with tiny vehicles I mean tiny
Vehicles compact cars little stick shift
compact cars that I rent it's stunning
when I don't drive that much and the gas
bill is 70 Euro and if in the United
States gas prices were similar to those
in Europe which are arguably more
accurate in representing the true cost
of a gallon of gas people would drive a
lot less and we would be doing less
damage to the environment and so while
by traditional economic standards
inflation down gas prices down stocks up
all of this stuff looks good
for Biden I also am painfully aware of
the fact that higher gas prices
encourage people to get off of gas
powered vehicles and move over to
electrics to drive less to look for a
more fuel-efficient vehicle so these are
all double-edged swords but by the
standard indicators we look at things
are looking really good doesn't mean
there isn't poverty inequality lack of
access to health care of course we
haven't solved the economy overnight but
many of the indicators Republican
themselves look at are looking very very
good
I have some incredible video to play for
you of Texas gubernatorial candidate
Beto O'Rourke saying to a member in the
audience who was laughing when he talked
about gun violence it's not funny to me
mother effer and I have to tell you I
love this we actually I've been saying
these people on the right
the currency they trade in is ignorance
reactionary ideology and humiliation
unfortunately
and Beto O'Rourke humiliated a Greg
Abbott supporter who laughed out loud
everybody heard it when Beto described
the killing of 19 Kids and two teachers
in Uvalde Texas
and Beto reacted in a way that is
entirely appropriate given the
circumstances take a look at this this
video going viral
that
that since we lost 19 kids and their two
teachers
shot to death with the weapon originally
designed for use in combat legally
purchased by an 18 year old who did not
try to obtain one when he was 16 or 17
but followed the law that's on the books
ladies and gentlemen that says that you
can buy not one you could buy two or
more if you want to
AR-15s hundreds of rounds of ammunition
and take that weapon that was originally
designed for use on the battlefields in
Vietnam to penetrate an enemy soldier's
helmet at 500 feet and knock him down
dead up against kids at five feet it may
be funny to you [ __ ] but it's
not funny
we're gonna make sure
oh the tone and he swore oh well when
Trump swears they love it this is sort
of the only appropriate reaction to
someone laughing at a horrifying story
of gun violence sometimes you got to
speak their language I mean these are
sick people this is the currency they
trade in and reports from inside the
event are that every single Abbott
supporter in the room was laughing as if
this were some kind of joke what
happened in Texas I would love to see
more Democrats just being able to speak
out like this it's genuine this is
better and not cowering when these
right-wing borderline domestic
terrorists start behaving the way that
they behave are deaths funny
is gun violence funny funny how what's
funny about it now this is a really
important race in Texas battle O'Rourke
is challenging the uh incumbent lunatic
Republican Governor Greg Abbott the
polling is not tremendously great for
Beto right now but I think this one is
very much worth fighting for if you look
at an average of recent polls Abbott is
ahead by just shy of eight points right
now is it Abbott's got about half of the
vote Beto's got about 42 percent so this
is I mean listen let's not sugarcoat it
this is not the easiest margin to
overcome but it's certainly possible and
it would be absolutely extraordinary to
be able to take this one from
Republicans so that's what's going on in
Texas good for Beto guys this is the
this is the understandable frustration
that we all should have with people who
laugh at gun violence with they laugh
and they want to do nothing about guns
doors they'll talk about Windows sinks
showers and toilets they'll talk about
but not guns we have a very interesting
new development in the for now
hypothetical 2024 Republican
Presidential matchup Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump are essentially even right
now in terms of the betting odds for
2024. now I want to remind everybody
this this is not polling okay this is
you go to predictit.org and you can bet
on who you believe will be the nominee
for the last many many months Donald
Trump has been the clear but
increasingly by a smaller margin
favorite in terms of the betting odds to
be the 2024 Republican nominee over the
last two days after the FBI served the
search warrant at Trump's home
uh Ron DeSantis actually pulled ahead
and then as of moments ago in a virtual
tie Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis for
2024 in terms of not who will you vote
for but who will you bet on being the
nominee
uh right now in order to win a dollar
you have to bet 37 cents on Donald Trump
being the nominee and in order to win a
dollar you have to bet 36 Cents on
DeSantis being the nominee it is a
virtual tie and every reason to believe
that this change is tied to the search
warrant and the increasing legal
problems for Trump trump pleading the
fifth more than 400 times yesterday
which I will talk about in the next
segment in terms of polling how does the
polling actually look it still favors
Trump very clearly new polls we have a a
Yahoo news poll uh Yugo Yahoo news poll
from Late July early August that has
Trump plus nine and then before that
um at the end of July a Harris Harbor
poll that has Trump plus like 30. okay
so it is tightening but also Donald
Trump is still clearly the favorite
among current Republican voters we are
going to be watching these numbers very
closely I don't want to spend a lot of
time on it today but we are certainly
going to be keeping an eye on it the
numbers are tightening and remember that
DeSantis hasn't announced anything Trump
hasn't either but Trump has been all but
announcing saying things like we might
have to do it again I think you're going
to be very happy with what we decide etc
etc it is not clear that Trump would
necessarily win a contested Republican
primary which would be an extraordinary
thing for a one-term president who lost
an unprecedented situation could be
facing Us in 2024
but we have 2022 coming up first and so
that's where our Focus will be let me
know your thoughts on where you see this
Republican primary going find me on
Twitter at dpacman we will talk about
pleading the fifth after this short
break
Donald Trump pleaded the fifth over 400
times yesterday after previously saying
only guilty people do it only the mob
pleads the fifth Hillary's staffers are
clearly guilty because they pleaded the
fifth so let's back up and talk about
what we are seeing here Donald Trump
yesterday was deposed by New York
attorney general Leticia James Donald
Trump did everything he could to avoid
having to testify to have to to be
deposed to give a deposition in this
investigation this is an investigation
into possible Financial Crimes by Donald
Trump's business including over and or
undervaluing assets depending on what he
was trying to achieve essentially
keeping two sets of books something you
were not allowed to do and as CNBC
reports Trump took Fifth Amendment more
than 440 times in refusing to answer New
York attorney general Leticia James
questions Donald Trump said he invoked
his Fifth Amendment right to refuse to
answer questions by investigators for
New York attorney general Leticia James
the scheduled deposition came days after
the FBI raided Mar-A-Lago
Trump's home as part of a criminal probe
James is investigating business
practices of the Trump organization
Trump's adult children Donald Trump Jr
Eric Trump and Ivanka previously
appeared for depositions in James's
probe as CNN also reports Donald Trump
declining to answer questions stating
that quote under the advice of my
counsel and for all of the above reasons
I declined to answer the questions under
the rights and privileges afforded to
every citizen under the United States
Constitution
and yet Donald Trump had very strong
views about the first of the fifth
amendment in the past
take a listen to this the mob takes if
it if you're innocent why are you taking
the Fifth Amendment oh when you have
your staff right taking the Fifth
Amendment taking the fifth
so they're not prosecuted when you have
the man that set up the illegal server
take in the fifth
I think it's disgraceful have you seen
what's going on in front of Congress
Fifth Amendment Fifth Amendment Fifth
Amendment
horrible horrible
yeah
well we know that there aren't really
any principles it's what can I say right
now that's convenient and makes me look
good
when years ago it was about this person
took the fifth and that person took the
fifth and you wanted to go after them
you say guilty people take the fifth
the mob takes the fifth innocent people
don't do that now Trump takes the fifth
and his explanation is that he now gets
it he now understands why people take
the fifth because he's being railroaded
and it's a Witch Hunt and on and on and
on and on they don't actually have any
principles whether it's on debt and
deficit whether it's on government
overreach and authoritarianism whether
it's on business regulation oh we're
against regulation oh Twitter doesn't
like anti-vaxx disinformation well now
we want to regulate Twitter and force
Twitter to have to publish anti-vaxx
disinformation there aren't actually any
principles and in a way
to you and me
this makes the movement
seem pathetic and it is it makes the
movement seem corrupt it makes it seem
vapid and it is all of those things but
to other people it doesn't matter these
right Wingers don't care they have the
same priority as Trump which is what can
I say today to make me look good what
can I say today I try to get out of this
on gas prices I don't play the games I
don't play the games of oh well the
president is a great participant in
reducing gas prices when it's a Democrat
and then I say something else when it's
a republican I don't play those games
but these Republicans the games is all
they have left unfortunately because
they've abandoned policy and so as I
said earlier in the week Herschel Walker
who doesn't want to debate his opponent
Rafael Warnock he should just start
saying Warnock won't debate me it's
completely made up but their followers
will eat it up and they will repeat it
and Trump's followers I saw some
interviews with them outside Mar-A-Lago
they're already saying the same thing oh
he's being railroaded of course he
should take the fifth oh but what about
all those times you said no no it
doesn't matter
Trump's being railroaded and that's the
bottom line so by his own standard only
guilty people do what he did let's now
talk about Trump's reaction to the
deposition
Donald Trump came out hot from his
deposition yesterday with New York
attorney general Leticia James Trump
pleaded the fifth more than 400 times
despite previously claiming only the mob
and guilty people plead the fifth and
then he spent the day absolutely losing
it on his platform truth social
take a look at what the president spent
the afternoon doing first of all posting
all sorts of different videos attacking
Leticia James and uh attack videos of
different kinds then saying at the very
plush beautiful and expensive Attorney
General's office nice working conditions
as people are being murdered all over
New York and she spends her time and
effort on trying to get Trump
Trump then continuing and posting this
entire statement about how Leticia James
campaigned on getting Trump and she's a
racist and she's hostile and she's just
determined to go after him a multi-page
tirade
uh that makes all absolutely no sense if
you've been following the facts of the
investigation Trump then continuing
about the raid saying he participated
and it was a surprise attack and it was
all without warning or notification
Trump then saying just leaving the
Attorney General's office a very
professional meeting having a fantastic
company with great assets very little
debt and lots of cash only in America
even that doesn't appear to be true at
this point about Donald Trump's
businesses Trump then posting a picture
of a police car outside Mar-A-Lago with
an article from the New York Post
uh posting that in fact multiple times
just spending his entire day posting all
of this stuff and he wants all of us to
believe things that are simply
unbelievable and not true Trump wants us
to believe that because he was
participating in conversations with the
FBI that the search warrant must have
been illegal or immoral in fact legal
experts have pointed out oh no no no the
fact that Trump was in contact with the
FBI and they still issued a search
warrant suggests that Trump was not
actually providing to the FBI what he
was supposed to provide it's it's not
better doesn't look better for Trump
that the warrant was served after he was
speaking them it actually looks worse
Donald Trump wants us to believe that
him even being deposed by Leticia James
is some horrible Act of unfairness and
Injustice and whatever else the case may
be this is a guy who has spent five
years
using every legal mechanism he could
think of to avoid releasing his taxes to
anyone including the house including
anybody despite claiming as soon as his
audits were over he would release them
who has spent the time avoiding having
to be deposed in sexual assault
allegation cases multiple of them which
I have told you about trying to avoid
providing all sorts of Records to all
sorts of different agencies who has
tried to avoid being deposed by Leticia
James on every single one of these
Donald Trump has gone above and beyond
what any normal person would be allowed
to get away with or could afford to get
away with and so with all the people who
have now come out of the woodwork from
the right saying you know we've got to
be really worried Trump's deposition the
search warrant at Mar-A-Lago if it could
happen to trump it could happen to any
of us it happens to all of us all the
time we're we the the two-tier justice
system is very clear and we deal with
this stuff all the time it's the trumps
of the world that often don't have to
deal with it and it's absolutely
stunning that now they are pulling all
of this so Donald Trump clearly with
much free time to just post and post and
post to truth social and the next
question becomes what is the next step
and I know that you know think about
Matt Gates we learned about the Matt
Gates child sex traffic investigation in
March of 2021.
nothing has really happened yet these
things can take a long time and I know
that there are many of you anxious to
see well what's the next thing what's
Leticia James going to do what's the doj
going to do after the search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago will it happen this week next
week the next week after that
Maybe
but this stuff can take months if not
years so my suggestion is let's take it
a day at a time right now the focus
really should be the 2022 midterms we
can't do anything about the timing of
these investigations into Trump we
actually can do something in November
which is voting and that means down
ballot and that means in every race
available for you to vote in that should
be the focus we will take a quick break
if you want to look at some of these
clips and posts find them on our
Instagram at davidpackman show we're
going to be back very very soon
today we're going to be speaking with
Catherine judge who's the Harvey J
Goldschmidt professor of law at Columbia
Law School and also author of the book
direct the rise of the middleman economy
and the power of going to the source
really great having you on I appreciate
your time
yeah thank you for having me so um I
think intuitively many in our audience
will will understand the concept of of
middlemen in the global economy and my
instinct is that at some point it was
quite logical to start seeing middlemen
as
um we started to see many Industries
scale international trade you know we
could think of reasons why why it made
sense what are the origins of so many
middlemen in so many of the industries
with which we regularly engage
I mean you really hit on a lot of the
drivers so the the middlemen are the
connectors through whom Goods flow
through money flows from people who have
it to to those who need it and both as
the economy got more Global but also as
it got more specialized uh we saw
proliferation of middlemen helping to
facilitate those transfers so you might
have you know investors with excess
capital in one country and limited
opportunities for return and so you
ended up initially with one and then
subsequently oftentimes layers of
middlemen that would help facilitate
flows to where there might be productive
undertakings uh even if that meant kind
of going moving the money abroad
similarly in production we know games
from trade is a is a classic idea and of
course we've had a shift from just
having Goods imported from one country
to another to really having globalized
Supply chains where goods are made in a
multi-continent undertaking with each
step kind of undertaking what it can do
most efficiently but of course as you
have that disaggregation of production
you need middlemen to help connect each
step along the way so before we we talk
about some of the downsides I mean it
seems accurate to say that in many cases
consumers do see lower prices on many
products as a result of middlemen is
that fair
that's certainly fair and one of the the
points of the book is actually middlemen
usually arrives because they're really
providing significant value and it
explores how overcoming the
informational and logistical challenge
is uh that can otherwise impede
transactions that make everybody better
off is a real value enhancing service to
provide so middlemen themselves are at
this point really the backbone of the
economy they're not going to go anywhere
soon but what the book explores is that
in a static environment you can look at
take a snapshot and it looks like
they're providing a lot of value and
oftentimes they are but the very nature
of what makes them so good at their jobs
also gives them the ability to exercise
outside influence on the evolution of
the market and the evolution of the laws
that are governing the spaces where
they're active that sometimes allows
them to extract more value and and lead
to potentially other challenges and
future periods and when you say that
because if I think of like Walmart and
Amazon
Walmart and Amazon are middlemen in a
sense in that they don't manufacture
most of the products they sell so in a
sense they've created this Marketplace
very convenient for all sorts of
different products but they also will
contract with other middlemen in many
cases as well so so they both are
middlemen and also are not depending on
which relationship we're thinking of
I mean is when you look the term
middlemen itself is very it's easy to
Define in the abstract but when you're
trying to apply that to particular
companies part of what you realize is a
lot of middle and men do provide
additional value along the way so their
primary role might be helping to
overcome informational or logistical
challenges but oftentimes they're doing
other things in the process right
um and so the the goal is to say look
it's not going to ever be a clear line
but conceptually it's helpful to
understand companies that are primarily
engaged in this business of connecting
and Amazon and Walmart are among them
they certainly have other activities
that they engage in Amazon was something
like Amazon web services is providing a
completely different uh type of value
proposition but but much of what they do
is make it so American consumers can
very readily access
and have enough information to trust to
buy Goods that were made on the other
side of the world so so there's
efficiencies there and there's a real
connection that's provided but there's
drawbacks uh one of the things that I
think is a concern for many in my
audience from the things we've talked
about is the ways in which sometimes
very large corporations will use
middlemen and or contractors to
um uh avoid accountability in some cases
sometimes point the finger at some other
entity either the Amazon delivery
services is one where often the vans
that we all see driving around are not
actually owned and operated by Amazon
even if they have Amazon painted
sometimes it's local LLC delivery
companies that own a bunch of Vans or
you know there's there's different
things is this one of the concerns with
this infrastructure where you have all
these different parties
it is one of the very significant
concerns uh so part of the challenge is
you know if you're just going directly
to the creator of a good not only
there's a relationship there but there's
clear accountability and any information
you want about that good you can readily
ascertain by asking the person or asking
for representations and warranties if
you want to be legalistic about the the
product but also about the nature of how
it was made and who was impacted and
part of what the book shows is that much
of the complexity of today's Supply
chains and the structure of these layers
of intermediaries grew up at a time
where we just assume investors wanted to
maximize the risk-adjusted returns and
consumers wanted nothing more than the
lowest price good you know holding
quality constant According to some
objective monitors but now we're in a
world where people suddenly realize the
government can't solve all of our
problems we actually care more about the
impact of the goods on the planet on the
workers and go through intentional use
of of middlemen to obso gate but also
just a byproduct of really complex
chains that were not necessarily
designed to create opacity but as a
practical matter have created that
opacity it is now virtually impossible
at times to understand I mean you can
look at your breakfast cereal and trying
to figure out where it all came from is
is oftentimes beyond the the average
consumer's capability and so as we're
bringing these additional values to the
table the accountability that people now
want is oftentimes very difficult if not
impossible to glob on top of the current
system yeah I mean in the kind of like
hipster Lefty space that I occupy
there's been a big move in the last five
years to go towards you know craft and
Independent Producers and products that
are not as widely available sometimes
that in and of itself is what makes them
more interesting and and I do think that
there is value to that because you know
if you think about like the the coffee
roasting industry instead of going to
your grocery store and grabbing the you
know so Allegro that's available
nationally or whatever you find some
local roaster and it's more interesting
and you know who's roasting it but it's
almost always more expensive and so it
it does seem that there is a very clear
Advantage at least in the minds of
consumers to that but there is certainly
a price associated with it
as I want to say a couple things on that
so first I love the coffee roasting
example one of the examples of my books
is Roost roosters which was a local
coffee roaster you know and I knew them
when they were small and they kept
growing but it is really nice and one of
the nice things about going direct is
even though it's more expensive you not
only learn a lot but you know where the
money's going so I actually feel a
little better about the money I'm
spending because I know the company I
know it's a local business I know all
the people involved I know how they
treat their employees so so I actually
feel better about the money I spent and
that is partly shifting from a world
where we had long assumed scarcity to
one whereas a practical matter even
though we still have a scarcity mindset
because that's how we're taught to think
so often we really live in a world of
abundance so making more selective
choices is oftentimes more rewarding
which is part of why you're seeing the
trends you are the final point I would
make is even though that's very often
true that right now direct is a little
bit of a privileged good or seems like a
privileged guide yeah
um it's more pervasive Than People
realize outside of cities so I get this
question all the time time from people
who live in relatively Urban
environments I live in an urban
environment
um but right now I'm not in our country
and part of what's been interesting
since I published the book is I'm
hearing from people in South Carolina
and Ohio in all of these different
states where they say this is exactly
what's already happening in my community
and actually there they're keeping all
of the value in their community and
they're not necessarily playing as much
as a premium because it's not the craft
Artisan that we think about in Brooklyn
or or kind of like a fun neighborhood as
much as somebody who's really just like
trying to create make additional money
by doing a product or a service on the
side and maintains competitive by having
good prices it's not going to be as
cheap as the mass-produced good in
Walmart partly because there you're
exploiting kind of these incredibly low
wage and worker protections uh in other
places but you really can
um
I think hit a broader set of the the
value spectrum that many of us
appreciate when it comes to supply chain
and some of the issues that we saw early
in the pandemic and then sort of again
and then even now to some degree and
we've seen you know baby formula and
different things it's not completely
obvious to me as someone who does not
share your level of expertise in this
issue whether the problem was made worse
or was actually resolved more quickly by
the kind of status quo of many middle
men in terms of Supply chains and the
way that products kind of get to the
shelves and ultimately into people's
homes what is the relationship or the
connection between those supply chain
issues we've seen over the last three
years and the existence of middlemen
so I would say in terms of the the risk
what we've seen arise it really can be
traced back to the proliferation of
middlemen
um but even though men have as you point
out I think accurately played a role in
helping us to address the challenges
part of what the direct documents uh is
the way middlemen proliferated slowly in
number to become more layered in ways
that really created these complex
ecosystems and generally speaking nobody
took a step back to look at the entire
complex ecosystem they were thinking we
can eat a little more cost savings here
a little more efficiency there and so
they kept making decisions that
incrementally were small but in
aggregate transformed the nature of the
system and then as we saw once there
were shifts whether it's East Mike and
demand or or limitations of Supply
because countries of Origins you know
were facing shutdowns there were Ripple
effects that magnified
that original distortion
because you had all of these suddenly
individual players that had depended on
the system working well
um having to figure out how to signal
you know what they wanted what they
needed in ways were they really looking
out for themselves and so you suddenly
ended up with people wanting like
demanding for more than they actually
needed because they're trying to hoard
and and really the distortions kept
getting bigger and what's interesting
for me is that this was actually one of
the original motivations for the book A
lot of my original work was on financial
regulation and looking at the way
securitization chains that proliferated
in the early odds contributed to the 07
and 08 crisis and we saw the exact same
thing there where we saw these chains
that grew so they were Capital Supply
chains as opposed to good Supply chains
but they grew incrementally over time
they appeared to make credit more
available so more people could buy homes
and that seemed like a really good thing
at the time because we could suddenly
tap in to these new pools of capital in
Germany and Japan to fund American Homes
but we created an incredibly complex
ecosystem where once things broke down a
little the the dysfunction magnified and
nobody had the information they needed
to help stabilize the the functioning
yeah it seems there's this interesting
example I remember from early in the
pandemic related to toilet paper whereas
you say people started wasn't that
people were using more in total but they
were buying more meaning they would be
stocked up for a longer period of time
and it was shifting from being at work
to being at home and one of the
questions a lot of people were asking
was well all of the companies that
deliver paper goods to businesses
shouldn't they just be able to redirect
that and put it in grocery stores or at
CVS or whatever the case may be and part
of the explanation was well
we're talking about different packaging
these things are not packaged for sale
in the same way and that's done much
earlier in the supply chain often before
it gets to the middlemen The Local
Company that that you go to also
sometimes like the toilet paper rolls
for businesses are gigantic you know it
just doesn't work at home but also the
company's doing the the servicing Office
Buildings don't have any connection
whatsoever to like CVS or Staples or
whatever so they were really a whole
bunch of things that would have had to
change now would it have been simpler if
the toilet paper manufacturers dealt
directly with everyone I don't know that
would have had its own share of problems
yeah and part of the book is really
nothing direct is the solution as much
as direct as the Cornerstone and a
Cornerstone really is a very very small
piece of a much larger larger edifice so
the point is saying we've gotten to this
hyper intermediated World we're
generally speaking the Instinct was
always to add additional layers of
middlemen but as you nicely pointed out
earlier there's already a counter
movement underway there's already a
number of people saying to be able to
really get what I want to have my values
match my actions I need to opt out of
the system entirely and so by
documenting both the growth of this
hyper intermediated world and this
revolution well then we can figure out
how to to navigate this territory in
between and the toilet paper is a great
example of it so as you're pointing out
the nature of the supply chains had
incredible rigidities which just meant
like they were used to doing one thing
and they couldn't easily change right
and oftentimes what we're seeing with
those rigidities the complexity really
accentuates them and it's not about
going direct but having fewer middlemen
and shorter chains can oftentimes
enhance resilience and enhance
flexibility so trying to figure out
where did we add layers over time
without anybody really understanding
well what are the states of the world uh
where things might go wrong and where
that might create problems or going back
to our earlier conversation where there
might be a lack of accountability
because now there's just no way for us
to actually see through all of the
different layers involved there are some
Industries where there's been a move
into a more direct model one of the ones
I think is interesting is you know for
for me the experience of going to car
dealers has never been good I mean it's
just it's not a pleasant experience very
low satisfaction with it for the average
consumer I ordered my last car online
it's a Tesla I didn't have to talk to
anybody I picked the features I wanted
there was no negotiation and then I got
a call when the car was ready and it was
a dramatically better experience now
this is all aside from all the other
concerns about Elon musk's tweets all
these different things I get that but as
an experience the dealership is a
terrible experience and it seems to me
that it would only make the end product
more expensive one report says on
average people pay about twelve hundred
dollars more for vehicles than they
otherwise would because of the the
dealership experience another one that
as many real estate agents that I have
in my Social Circle that I think could
be eliminated is the idea that a realtor
regularly takes you know a slice out of
every real estate transaction can sell
the same house multiple times in many
countries you just deal with a lawyer
and you don't need the entire
infrastructure of the real estate agent
it you could potentially cut out a
middleman can you talk about either of
those Industries and or other industries
that have done well at moving to a more
direct model
so both absolutely outstanding examples
I spent a lot of time on residential
real estate and the car market fits
equally well and I'd actually done a
huge amount of research and only left it
out because I had so many other great
examples yeah so the great thing about
your Tesla example is yes it was a
better experience and contrary to our
earlier conversation it was cheaper
you're cutting out an expensive
middleman and you're saving real money
and same thing in residential real
estate we know for your average middle
class family the median family United
States they don't have most of their
money in stocks and bonds housing is our
number one source of wealth so when Real
estate's come all Agents come in and
take five percent on average even now of
every single real estate transaction you
are eating directly out of the bottom
line the nest egg of your typical middle
class family in a very meaningful way
now many of the real estate agents in
their defense are also middle class
right I mean there's two sides to that
to be fair
yeah the hard thing with a real estate
agent is there's some really good
research just showing that we have too
many of them so they provide very real
value but it's relatively easy to become
a real estate agent so what we've seen
is there's some great work showing you
know comparing for example Minneapolis
and Boston and saying look when housing
prices were about the same uh each agent
sold on average like 10 houses a year or
12 houses a year and then suddenly the
Boston housing market went crazy so a
decade later what happened
real estate agents in Minneapolis were
still selling 10 to 12 houses a year
real estate agents in Boston their
income is about the same but they were
suddenly selling on average four to five
houses a year and that's because so the
commissions went up because there were
percentage of sales so so many more
people became real estate agents and
then so what do they all do they send
out like really glossy mailings to
people who already own their homes just
saying like choose me if you're gonna
sell so it's not actually against the
real estate agents themselves it's a
system that doesn't serve the agents and
really doesn't serve homeowners right
and one nice things about both the the
car market and the real estate at Market
is they are examples where there have
been state laws across numerous states
that entrench the current system
so for example if you look at
penetration of electric vehicle sales
one of the most significant indicators
is do you have state laws that
effectively entrench the the need to use
a car dealership doesn't New Jersey have
such a law
yeah and I so I should double check but
a number of a number of states do and 10
states still have things projecting
effectively effectively prohibiting
rebates because really for real estate
it's the buy side more than the sell
side where one where a lot of countries
have managed to get rid of the agent so
oftentimes sellers need a little more
hand-holding but you're also paying a
lot to a buyer where they're doing their
own work on Zillow or Redfin but of
course what you're really tapping into
there is the MLS which is still
controlled by full service real estate
agents and so those are both great
examples where when you really look at
the mechanisms they are layered and a
little complicated but where you see
people who came in originally and
provided value and then in a post
internet era
where there's so much more ability for
consumers to do things for themselves we
should have had a change in the market
structure but the change has been
relatively modest relative to the cost
savings and the Alternatives that open
up and it's partly because the the
entrenched metalmen really do a good job
to
to undermine the the Alternatives that
otherwise would be available both
through Market mechanisms and through
through legal mechanisms yeah justifying
their own their own existence
essentially uh the book is direct the
rise of the middleman economy and the
power of going to the source we've been
speaking with the book's author
Catherine judge who teaches law at
Columbia Law School thank you so much
for your time today I really appreciate
it thank you for having me
whenever there's a major Scandal That
Rocks the political world it sometimes
takes a little while to figure out which
talking points uh politicians are going
to attach themselves to and in the
immediate aftermath of the FBI serving
the search warrant on Donald Trump's
Mar-A-Lago earlier this week we heard a
bunch of different things floated from
Republicans we heard about this could be
the start of an assassination attempt
that made no sense there's no evidence
of that we heard about this as an
abusive power we heard all sorts of
different things but the one that they
seem to be sticking with is the FBI
planted evidence now the Trump people
have not even released the search
warrant and it seems as though they're
not going to the latest reports I saw
this morning are that they are not
releasing the search warrant there is
absolutely no evidence whatsoever that
the FBI plan did anything there is also
it's sort of hard to believe that in a
case this high profile that that is the
approach that the FBI would take if
anything my instinct is that the FBI
would rather not have done this at all
because all of a sudden now Merrick
Garland's getting death threats
Christopher Ray is getting death threats
it's crazy what is going on I don't
think that this is something they would
do just for fun but put that aside for a
second they are sticking with the FBI
planted evidence I had half a dozen
examples for you of this over the last
couple of days and now people in greater
and greater positions of Power are
starting to repeat this one here is
Republican senator Rand Paul who is also
floating without any evidence whatsoever
that the FBI may be planting evidence
take a listen to this and it's it's seen
as acceptable by many on the right for
Rand Paul to make this claim absent any
reason to believe it's true no people
distrust so much the government that
we've gotten to the point where for
example do I know that the boxes of
material they took from Mar-A-Lago that
they won't put things in those boxes to
entrap him how do we know their lawyers
weren't allowed to see the boxers go
they weren't categorized thousands of
documents were taken well Rand is there
any reason to believe that such a thing
was done because for everybody
mentioning the planting of evidence no
one has been able to present any actual
reason to believe that that happened how
do we know that they're going to be
honest with us about what's actually in
the boxes how do we know that was in the
Box before it left the residents if the
lawyers weren't allowed to see
everything so you know they've lost a
great deal of trust and it's uh yeah so
there's Rand Paul asserting it and this
is sort of the anatomy of a conspiracy
theory it will often start sort of
quietly as an aside with the most
partisan people Trump's lawyers for
example going listen it wouldn't shock
me if they even planted evidence oh yeah
yeah yeah and then people like Fox News
hosts start uh latching onto it and we
played a number of examples of that from
yesterday and next thing you know
sitting senators and sitting members of
Congress are doing the same thing it
almost seemed like Marjorie Taylor
Greene got it from an oan host here is
Marjorie Taylor green yesterday nodding
along as an oan host says maybe evidence
was planted and then I'll show you how
later in the day she makes it her own
and all of the all of the documents and
everything president Trump had at
Mar-A-Lago that has been anything that
the FBI needed to raid his home for that
no we already talked about that or the
GSA approved it the the GSA approved the
documents mailed them sealed them and
sent them to him so why would the
government give them to him for now the
government to come take them back that's
completely untrue by the way but that's
not the focus today unless they're
planting something anyway I gotta switch
back because we're literally almost out
of time merge I knew this would happen
because you and I are so Marjorie Taylor
green saying about they unless they plan
to plant evidence yeah and right and
then later in the day Marjorie Taylor
green going full-fledged in on this
tweeting quote I think now look at the
language right I think so that's your
that's your thinking you don't have
evidence I think that there is an
extremely high probability that the FBI
planted evidence against President Trump
otherwise why would they not allow his
attorneys or anyone watch them while
they conducted their unprecedented raid
they know the consequences of an
empty-handed power move this Rings
completely and totally Hollow it just
doesn't pass the sniff test and let me
also talk a little bit about Marjorie
Taylor Green's use of the word
unprecedented yesterday
um we talked about Marcia Blackburn's
comment if they can do this to Trump
they can do this to anyone to which we
said they already do it to anyone the
question is will they ever do it to
people in positions of power the other
one that Trump and others have been
talking about is that this was an
unprecedented raid first of all I you
know I've been guilty of this as well
the FBI doesn't really do raids I mean
this wasn't really a raid they had a
search warrant and they served it that
that's what that's what it was it was a
search warrant they executed a search
warrant so the use of raid it's
colloquially used and I do it as well
but understand that this this was they
served a search warrant unprecedented is
a big Focus for them Trump said no this
has never happened to any president
before
and now a lot of these right-wingers
have latched on to the idea of
unprecedented well if it's never been
done before then it must be wrong we've
never had a president who did the things
that Donald Trump did
so it's logical that where I mean sort
of like a mathematical equation when you
have unique inputs you will have a
unique output and we're starting with
the president who did things no other
president has done it's logical it would
be to be expected that the outcomes also
are unlike those that we have seen
before and one such outcome is indeed a
search warrant being served by the FBI
on Donald Trump's home there is no
evidence that they planted evidence if
we ever learned that the FBI planted
evidence I will tell you that and I will
absolutely condemn it for now there's no
reason to think that that took place
we are increasingly seeing reporting
that the reason for all of this trouble
at Mar-A-Lago is a traitor or a mole
inside Donald Trump's circle now there's
a couple different elements to this one
is is there a high level Trader like
Mark Meadows Mark Meadow's name is one
that is frequently mentioned but then
there's also a more nitty-gritty
question of like is there just someone
at Mar-A-Lago that has been involved in
feeding information to the feds about
where things are being kept in Donald
Trump's home or whatever the case may be
increasingly seeing more and more
reporting on this Business Insider
quoting axios Trump allies think there's
a traitor in Mar-A-Lago who informed on
him to the FBI allies of trump believe
an aid or Aids to Trump may have flipped
and provided evidence to the FBI about
what he was keeping in his Mar-A-Lago
Resort in Florida per axios when we look
at the axios report
one big thing Trump World suspects a
flipper
Trump World is a buzz with speculation
about which close AIDS or Aid has
flipped and provided additional
sensitive information to the FBI about
what Trump was keeping there
Trump's orbit is always an environment
Rife with mistrust and paranoia and it
is intensified in a detail that seems
too novelistic to be true a focal point
of the search was the Mar-A-Lago
basement Christina Bob a lawyer for
Trump told the Washington Post his
lawyers held discussions with the
justice department this spring Bob said
Trump's legal team searched through two
dozen two to three dozen boxes in a
basement storage area hunting for
documents that could be considered
presidential records Bob told the post
that in June Trump lawyers showed those
boxes to investigators and they already
looked through it she said the
investigators didn't think the storage
unit was secured so Trump officials
added a lock
FBI agents broke through the lock during
the search and then took a dozen boxes
Newsweek also exclusively reporting an
Informer told the FBI what documents
Trump was hiding and where the raid on
Mar-A-Lago was based largely on
information from an FBI confidential
human Source who was able to identify
what classified documents Trump was
still hiding in the locations the
officials who have direct knowledge of
the FBI's deliberations were granted
anonymity
said the rate of Trump's home was
deliberately timed to occur when Trump
was away
FBI decision makers in Washington and
Miami thought that denying Trump a photo
op or a platform from which to
grandstand or try to thwart The Raid
would lower its profile that failed it
prompted a furious response from
Republican leaders
this is completely plausible
as with many of these things
we often because of the documentation
being not public we often don't
understand and because of the need to
protect informants we often never learn
everybody that is in touch with law
enforcement in advance of such an action
but it would be completely reasonable to
think that something like this took
place Marjorie Taylor green believes it
and she's on the case and she wants the
Traders found I do not want him in there
and they're so hell-bent on it guess
what we now know that there was an FBI
informant at marlago an FBI informant
working at Mar-A-Lago by the way she
says she knows this based on media
reports the very same media she often
decries as fake news that tells lies
again it's just what's convenient for us
right now right now it's convenient to
believe those reports in the media is
and how many other FBI informants are
around president Trump on a daily basis
working at his clubs working at
Mar-A-Lago or maybe bedminister or on
bed Minister I I know that's completely
uh an aside
Bedminster bed Minister please Marjorie
staff these are the things I want to
know because they're traitors they are
Traders and they're helping the Deep
State and they're helping the people
these are the enemies Within These are
the real enemies and they are there to
purposefully purposely create something
against President Trump that is not
there it's absolutely not there and
everyone knows it everyone knows it and
if these people say so traitor is the
word that Marjorie Taylor green and
quite frankly many in Maga world are
using will we ever learn who it was
probably not but from a political
standpoint at a bigger picture level
Mark Meadows has never publicly accused
Cassidy Hutchinson of lying during her
testimony to the January 6th committee
and so merely speculatively
it seems to me quite plausible that
Meadows is somewhere involved in
providing information to someone not
could be FBI could be January 6 maybe I
don't know
but his silence when many others have
said Cassidy is lying is very notable uh
that's probably separate from whatever
so-called Trader was at Mar-A-Lago
probably two different stories we have a
voicemail number and that number is 219
to David P if you have anything to say
comment question concern complaint you
can call 2192 David P you know in the
midst of all of these problems for the
right here's a caller reminding us about
a very important story that no one's
talking about anymore listen to this
uh Dave this is Chuck from Minneapolis
they could have rated
the Obamas for that
if you forgot about Obama gay you know
what it is all right thanks bye yep
whatever happened with Obama gate you
might remember that during Donald
Trump's first and so far only
presidential term he started talking
about obamigate which he described as
the greatest political crime of the
century when he was asked sir what is
Obama gate he angrily told a reporter in
the Press briefing room you know what it
is and no one knows what it is but if
there is anything ripe for a raid
I guess it would be this vague Obama
gate I don't know we have a great bonus
show for you today in the midst of all
of this economic good news and bad Mega
news Joe Biden's approval rating has
spiked to its highest point in two
months things are really turning around
for this guy we're going to talk about
it on the bonus show we will also talk
about a new report that says rainwater
is not safe to drink because of the
chemicals that are in it and we will
talk about the growing sort of I hate to
call it this but it's kind of a pissing
match between Apple and Samsung or
really iPhone and Android we're texting
between the two platforms is
increasingly broken I'm going to explain
to you what's going on in the behind the
scenes of it very very interesting uh
corporate Wars all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show Batman's a
loser Alex Jones hates the bonus show I
love the bonus show and I would love for
you to sign up at joinpakman.com see you
there today or tomorrow tomorrow on the
Friday